we will hear from three speakers
um firstly matt ducey member of
parliament for waimakariri
charlene sterling who's the chair of the
rangiora community board
and then mayor david ears each
speech will be supported from the
council's wyatta group who are here in
the front and they will perform
at the conclusion of each speech at that
point
the mayor will unve unveil the plaque i
was lucky enough to have a sneak preview
of the new rangyora town hall this week
i was really impressed by the size of
the town hall
an auditorium an auditorium a theatre
and two boutique cinemas a function room
music rehearsal rooms and even a green
room
although i would have preferred it to be
called a blue room
following the canterbury earthquakes we
lost a great many of our community
facilities
these buildings represent more than just
bricks and mortar
they bring a community together i think
we can all agree that we have rebuilt
bigger and better not only is a ring or
a town hall earthquake strengthened
but the new features will meet the
future demands of
our growing population waimakariri
is truly becoming a destination of
choice
foreign
this is more than just a building in
fact i might i do believe it may hold a
little magic
we could even call our town hall our own
tardis
as it is larger on the inside than it
appears on the outside
and also for the possibility of the
unexpected journeys
of creating memories you may go on as
you enter
our new town hall will be used for a
variety of purposes
movies live theater ceremonies and
events
all which will bring us together as a
community to enlighten
entertain and encourage our town hall
also has the power to provide a sense of
joy and achievement to our community
offering the opportunity to provide a
number of first-time experiences
such as the first time performing on
stage
the first time feeling the appreciation
of an applause
and maybe even the first time of a kiss
in the back
or maybe just the first time in a long
time
a town hall really can and should be
part of the heart of our community and i
hope as we enjoy this building
once again it does in fact become a
centre for us all to share
and use as as we can all experience a
little bit of magic
while today has been many years in the
making even decades
it's also another step in our district's
earthquake recovery
it's also a great day for canterbury
because every step towards
recovery whether it's in our public
buildings like this
new houses replacing those lost new
commercial premises
community groups getting back on their
feet they are all part of our province's
recovery and the rebuild
it's a great day for waimakariri because
rangiora is one of our two main towns
and is important for the whole district
that rangiora is doing well
and it's a great day for rangiora
because one of the town's most loved
buildings is back
and better than ever rangiora and
waimakariri
are on the way back here okay
it's a great pleasure to officially
reopen
the rangora town
so
you